I think I lost around like
most in a single trade probably around
sixty thousand dollars I think losing
was probably one of the best things
losing trades I think are a gift in
Disguise because it gives you more
awareness of what you have to do and
what to solve your mistakes and also
gives you the right mentality
[Music]
can you tell me what was your childhood
like
so I I think I started off pretty you
know you the regular kid you know
Finding dopamine anything you could
trying to find fun all around and uh I
think it was around the age of seven
years old is when I first discovered
this sense of Entrepreneurship so
essentially
um I I got gifted a 3D printer I started
printing off quite ridiculous things
like little objects and toys and then I
realized that you could actually you
know print more um useful objects so I
started printing off with the phone
cases and then later on um I brought one
to school which had like a custom
designer to one of my friends said oh
that's quite cool uh can you give me one
and then I was like okay sure so I did
and then a lot of people started asking
for these cases so then I ended up just
sitting like okay I don't have to pay
for the materials I don't have that much
and I'm like okay why not I actually
started selling them so then I started
off selling these 3D printed phone cases
and then I ended up making a website for
them because I made websites even
earlier than that because I I liked you
know web designing that type of stuff
um and then I started selling them
online and I think that was like my
first time I started shipping a physical
item it was quite you know a weird
experience and then I think at around
the age of 10 years old is when I got
into the stock space so
my dad he wasn't investing in stocks
also like me I asked him what is stocks
because I heard it online when I was
researching and then they said stocks
are basically you buy a share of a
company you buy a little bit of a
company and every single time that
company does well you get you get
rewarded for that as your you that parts
of the company you own is more valuable
I started getting into the uh the first
stock I got in with the um Vanguard S P
500 that was like the first it was an
ETF stock which essentially the 500
biggest companies in America all bundle
into one stock which is extremely safe
because it's um it's a low growth low
risk low reward type of stock and then I
think at the age of 12 and 13 I started
venturing out in different branches of
the stock world so then I discovered
something called cryptocurrency mining a
cryptocurrency is a medium of exchange
similar to your regular cryptocurrencies
like your British pound your American
dollar your Euro however the one
distinct difference between the
cryptocurrencies and regular everyday
currencies are it isn't attained it
isn't legal tender it isn't maintained
by a central Banker entity it's owned by
everyone so essentially there's no one
controlling all the functions of the
cryptocurrency how does the rise of
Bitcoin then happen like how does it
work oh so basically with how Bitcoin
miners get rewarded is um when you're
sending transactions out to people uh
there's a small transaction fee
depending on your cryptocurrency these
fees will vary from like Bitcoin which
can result depending if you use just
regular Bitcoin transaction will be
around a couple dollars maybe tens of
dollars uh if you use the most expensive
Network currently called ethereum it
could cost up to hundreds of dollars uh
and basically these fees when you send a
transaction they get sent directly to
those miners some coins may have
different tokenomics so tokenomics
basically mean the uh the economic model
of the coin and how coins were
distributed with uh Bitcoin a hundred
percent of the coins in the fees get
sent to the um people so let's say I uh
I send a Bitcoin transaction to you
worth a hundred dollars it'll probably
be maybe seven dollar fee in those that
that seven dollars would be sent to
those miners who validate my transaction
you're under 18.
what's the choice of cryptocurrency also
because you could legally trade it
without any any problem
I think the wonderful thing about
cryptocurrency is that a lot of people
are catching aspects on is
cryptocurrencies are so new there's no
government regulation or there's little
government regulation if I were to go
and try and open a stock account I
wouldn't be allowed like opening a
trading account was one of the hardest
things I've done I had to use my parents
and it was a big mess when they tried
giving their account to me and with the
taxes and all these legal issues even
though with an Isa uh it's tax-free with
crypto the beauty about crypto is it's
unregulated and some people might see
that as a scary thing however the people
themselves set their own regulation what
I mean by that is that people determine
their own rules people create their own
coins anyone can create a coin it's it
can if you have the knowledge you can
create one that's the beauty of
cryptocurrencies
can you give me an idea of how much
money did you make on crypto overall
uh I don't want to give can I like skip
this because I don't want to give an
exact figure can you give me like just
an idea can you say that it's like over
a million at least yeah okay
how much have you lost in one day
I think I lost around like
most in a single trade probably around
sixty thousand dollars I think losing
was probably one of the best things
losing trades I think are a gift in
Disguise because it gives you more
awareness of what you have to do and
what to solve your mistakes and also
give you the right mentality because
most of these people who've never lost
cryptocurrency or lost trades before and
they're getting to cryptocurrency new
when they see their coins have dipped 20
they're panicking however people who
already experienced with this they know
it's it's nothing new because at the
same time it is quick dopamine that's
the reason why people get into
cryptocurrencies for financial incentive
yes but the same time the feeling you
get once you make those gains is not
comparable to anything else the best
thing I think about stocks and
cryptocurrency is um your work pays off
you do an hours of research on some
coins you you talk to different people
you hold them for a while and then when
you see that that green percentage
number and you see that the coins are up
it's that feeling you get like your hard
work has paid off and that's what I like
about cryptocurrency is because yes
cryptocurrency can make it can change
people's lives but also it's a feeling
you get like you've actually
accomplished something when you're
trading and then you see a loss of like
you lost in a day 500 pounds or 1 000
pounds or something similar to this
right
even if you're not financially that well
off you would be like oh okay that sucks
whatever you'd be quite annoyed but you
forget about the next day however
that's that's the issue because you only
see us digits on the screen but then
let's say you're walking on the street
and you dropped 1 000 pounds off your
pocket and then it just flew away in the
wind you would feel way worse off than
trading because trading it feels like a
game feels like digits on the screen
people get lost into it and they don't
realize the impact it has on their
financial lives because believe it or no
that's real money feel free to
experiment like I wasn't uh good at
trading from the beginning or investing
at the beginning I was experimenting at
the same time be reasonable with your
amounts treated as if it's real money
instead of just some game
there is quite a lot of you know Tick
Tock and YouTube accounts where people
give uh yeah Financial advice about
crypto Investments what do you think
about all of those with cryptocurrency
even though there's a lot of
tremendously good advice that's also
diluted with a lot of bad advice
there's one thing where on Tick Tock
basically
Tick Tock creators they don't make money
from Trading they make money by being an
influencer they make money by people
clicking on their videos and liking them
and sharing them out so the algorithm
can pick up their views and they get
something from The Tick Tock Creator
program or they get more followers I
don't know however the really good
advice is the boring advice it's a
device no one wants to hear if I were to
go to tell you and then let's say
someone who's heard about this exciting
new thing cryptocurrency and they ask me
how do I invest I would tell them oh buy
these coins hold them for a long period
maybe a couple months to a year you'll
be up 100 they'll be like oh double my
money in a couple months like they
wouldn't be that excited but all of that
said do you still believe that
cryptocurrencies will shape the future
of financial markets think of
cryptocurrency now as the 1998 just
before the tech center one is starting
to Boom cryptocurrencies now are
extremely undervalued because the use
case they bring can completely
revolutionize the world I can Envision a
future where 10 years instead of saying
oh PayPal me this amount I could say uh
oh yeah send me this via ethereum or
something like this or send me this
point because I don't know what coins
will be available in the future a lot of
good coins will come up but
cryptocurrency in general has a lot of
evolution to come to it
what do your parents think about what
you do my parents
um
yeah like my mother didn't really
understand most about cryptocurrencies I
helped her get into it because like
she's quite adventurous like me she
likes you know she likes experiments
with these types of things she started
asking me more about Bitcoin ethereum I
was on trade because she was interested
in these types of crypto so that I just
showed her how to invest I helped her
set up an exchange account
um and then yeah she started buying it
to different coins and she's quite happy
with the result now I think
do you still go to school yes I do go to
school did you have did you have any
thoughts about like living it because I
mean you're really kind of getting on
with your life and making money so I
have had a lot of thoughts of leaving it
however I do want to go to university
um I think leaving school now I could
definitely leave school now have however
I think so far my workload between
balancing school and balancing my work
uh you know my work outside school is
okay if it gets much much worse I would
have to contemplate it before now I can
definitely handle both so why not you
know
what is your dream
my dream
uh I've quite a lot of dreams and
ambitions
huh I think my biggest dream ever would
be to um it would be to revolutionize
the education system I think that's my
greatest dream I think the biggest thing
with the biggest error with the
education system is the financial
literacy side of it I think a lot of
people criticize me on this and say oh
you don't need to teach a bunch of kids
Financial Independence Etc right they'll
learn it when they're adults however I'm
not talking about things like investing
in some complex things because those are
things unless you actually enjoy them
you won't want to do them you don't need
to invest if you want to invest sure but
you don't need to it isn't a thing you
need to learn however there are simple
things that I cannot believe are taught
at a young age such as
most countries can get a bank account at
the age of 12. however the school will
never tell you to get a bank account
they never tell you to save I think
credit scores are a big part of our
world I disagree with credit scores
however they're necessary however
there's ways to improve your credit
score at 16 years olds by co-signing on
your parents uh credit card and uh
improving your credit score and that'll
tremendously help you because by the age
of 18 you can buy multiple you can get
loans at way cheaper rates right and pay
them back at uh with more LAX deadlines
I think Basic Finance is definitely
necessary at a young age to teach there
should definitely be a finance
curriculum piled around all the other
stuff they teach you at the young age
and I think our generation is definitely
looking bright because even though we
have a lot of bad things like high
inflation rates high rent all these
types of stuff I think we can eat combat
it easier because we have an easier
access to information we're all
connected to each other through social
media through Google through forums Etc
it was like I don't know midnight one
o'clock in the morning I actually
flicked the website back on and in the
first half an hour of the website being
live we sold 30 000 pound in product so
to go from 300 quid a day to 30 000
pound in half an hour
um everything had sold out it was um it
was absolutely mind-blowing